[Music]
the 1970s the first Black Panther
service was being done
you weren't obviously a lot of black
characters pop culture was not where it
is now as you guys doing this from I
wish we had the backing in terms of
people believing in the project they
felt they would give me a book that was
going to die the Black Panther wasn't an
important character but the reason that
we got to do what we did was because
they didn't have time to read those
books they could onto I think about
three foresters in and then say hey wait
a minute
but it was too late it's already a novel
and then I could do it what made it
unique was just the idea at the time not
only was this a black superhero and it
was kind of a shock when he's pulls off
his mask and reveals himself to be an
African King but he's also rich very
smart yeah the king of a kingdom and he
single-handedly defeats Marvel's premier
family group the Fantastic Four and this
was all being done and delivered to a
largely white and male audience at the
time so it was kind of a shock wave in a
sense and delivered at a time of civil
unrest during the growth of the civil
rights movement and it just showed what
a progressive thinker Stan was and still
is to this day